Ohhh...
MARKIPLIER SINGS (BY ACCIDENT)
Le- Let's di- Let's dive in...
*Confused Markimoo*
I don't know how to do this,
I don't know how to do this...
I think I know, but I don't really know...
Where am I gonna go?
Don't know... Okay...
I'M FUBBER-NUCKED ANYWAY!
So FLYYY! (like a butterfly).
Like a ButterFLYYY!
I won't keel over and DIE!
I'm on fire,
The fire RISES!
*That face tho*
There's nowhere to hide here...
So FLY!
Like a ButterFLYYYYY!
Oh say can you see,
How boned I am?
*Well, yeah*
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy,
How boned I am?
It's only 1 AM...
I don't know if I'm doing anything right...
We all do...
I'M A SLEEPY BABY!
TURN OUT THE LIGHT!
Don't look back....
I'm not gonna look back.
No matter what you tell me,
I'm not gonna do that!
No matter how long,
No matter how strong
I wanna look back,
No way
in hell,
that I would ever look back.
*Mark looks back* (MARKS A LIAR! -Editor)
So FLY! (like a butterfly)
Like a butterFLY!...
I won't keel over and DIE!
I'm on fire-
The fire RISES!
*We need a new Plier for this dude... Any suggestions?*
There's nowhere to hide here...
So FLY!
Like a butterFLY!
Mmmm, La La La Laaaa! *Darkimoo!!!*
I don't know if I'm doing anything right...
Mmmm, La La La Laaaa!
Who the bingle bonger binker built this?!
Mmmm La La La Laaaa!
That's one for me in the win column! (MARKIFLY..Idk. -Editor)
A lot of losses but still, at least I'm in the game!
Mmmm La La La Laaaa!
I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU ARE!...
AAAH!
I think I'm going crazy... *We all are*
Mmmm LaLaLaLaaaa
Oh ho
WHY, Freddy?
WHY, Freddy?!
WHY, FREddy?!
WHY, FREDDY?!
WHYYYYYYYYYY???
*Bonnie sternly stares at Markiplier's terrified soul*
So FLY! (like a Butterfly)
Like a butterFLYYY!
I won't keel over and
DIE!!!!!!!
I'm on fire-
The fire RISES!
There's nowhere to hide here...
There's nowhere to hide here....                  *No seriously, is this a Plier yet?*
So FLY!
Like a butterFLY!
Like a butterfly...
I won't keel over and DIE!
I'm on fire-
The fire RISES!
There's nowhere to hide here...
So FLY,
Like a butterFLYYYYY!
*Is this a Plier yet also? I'm not sure...*
(I honestly have no idea what to do...)
TOUCH THE BOX!
AND YOU CAN GET THE TRACK!
AND EVERY DAY!
EVERYWHERE!
YOU CAN HAVE A HAPPINESS ATTACK! *more like butterfly attack*
SUB TO MARK! (And JBMagination too)
AND SUB TO SCHMO! (And JBMagination too)
WE'LL BE WITH YOU THROUGH RAIN AND SNOW! (and sleet and hail)
AND BUTTERFLY DREAMS OF INDIGO! (and any other color)
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHHHHHHHHHH!